first time I was homeless I was twenty
two and a half years old and I had a two
and a half year old son I was born a
very normal family and poor family there
were times when it was hard to imagine
that my life would be what it is today
especially the time when my son and I
were living in that bathroom
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna look at seven
inspirational rags to riches stories
enjoy coming up first is John Paul
DeJoria whose advice is to take control
first time I was homeless I was twenty
two and a half years old and I had a two
and a half year old son I was working as
the master of ceremonies at the second
annual sports vacation recreational
vehicle show and had a check coming in
at the end of the week well I came home
and I drove her a one-car up to where we
lived and as I was getting out of the
car and going up towards our apartment
door my wife we very young by we got
married at 20 and 19 years old my wife
was coming down the stairs and she said
one of the story she took the keys by
the time I got through the door I saw my
little boy two and a half years old kind
of just sitting there on top of a pile
of clothes with a note that basically
said I can't handle being a mom anymore
he'll be much better off with you good
luck now what I didn't know also was
that she had planned this for a few
months she had not paid the rent for a
few months and kept the money and I
didn't know that she wiped out what
little we had in the savings account in
the bank and took the only car we had so
unbeknownst to me two days later I was
evicted completely affected power shut
off the landlord she just really timed
this one and I had this little kitten
with me two and a half years old and
nine to be mom and dad and that was
really a bummer and no car so I ended up
borrowing the 1951 Cadillac with a
broken water pump from someone that was
very very dear have put water in it
every four hours and that's kind of how
we got going second time I was homeless
is when I started John Paul Mitchell
Systems I knew I needed half
million dollars to start John Paul
Mitchell Systems had to have that so we
had the backer lined up I had a good job
at the time that a nice house and I left
everything I had because half a million
dollars was coming in down the street I
was in starting company so I left it all
behind I left what money I had with my
wife we working along well at all and
the best car and I took the older car
was a good one but an older car rammed
good down the hill to get my money I
would check into an efficiency hotel and
then because I'd be traveling a lot and
eventually in an apartment when I went
down the hill the backer pulled out no
money there I was a few hundred dollars
in my pocket too proud to ask my mother
if I could have my old room back for my
in the home and she could feed me for a
couple months I get back on my feet and
I just left my living situation I was
too proud stupid but very very proud so
I went by and saw my mom and uh you know
it was borrowed a couple hundred dollars
from her I said mom we'll give it back
to you she said son you're doing really
well in life why didn't a few hundred
dollars as a mom I give it back to him
I'm starting something new and that's
when I decided I'm gonna make it I'm not
gonna tell her
lived in my car shower down at Griffith
Park because they had tennis courts
there was showers in it and or not live
off very little and go ahead and sell
products door-to-door Story number two
is Jack Ma whose advice is to be
resourceful I was born a very normal
family and poor family six people sure
$7 mouth we can only eat one chicken a
year what's terrible
Nixon visits in my city 1972 China USA
signed a Mao Zedong Nixon signed the
agreement so China become opened oh my
City Council was one of the first cities
that opened to the west we got a lot of
American tourists to visit my city what
he would do is he would befriend foreign
visitors who came to Hangzhou
the Westlake there and I learn English
by being a free guide for tour guide you
know more than the language Jack was
learning about the culture the things I
learned from books from China are so
different from the things I learned from
the American visitors so I start to
think differently Story number three is
Oprah Winfrey whose advice is to
envision a greater future I was raised
on a farm with my grandmother for the
first six years of my life I knew
somehow that my life would be different
and it would be better I never had a
clear-cut vision of what it was I would
be doing I just always felt somehow I
remember absolutely physically feeling
it at around four years old I remember
standing on the back porch was a
screened-in porch and my grandmother was
boiling clothes because you know during
the at that time we didn't have washing
machines and so people would you know
physically boil clothes and a great big
iron pot she was boiling closing poking
them there and I was watching her from
the back porch and I was four years old
and I remember thinking my life won't be
like this my life won't be like this it
will be better and it wasn't from a
place of arrogance it was just a place
of knowing that things could be
different from me somehow I don't know
what made me think that Story number
four is Chris Gardner whose advice is to
own your life as Joey as strangers
change can be there were times when it
was hard to imagine that my life would
be what it is today especially the time
when my son and I were living in that
bathroom maybe remember that scene in
the movie there was a highly polished
sheet metal piece over a sink it wasn't
a mirror but it served as a mirror and I
had to wash myself in that baby every
day watch my baby in this sink and had
to ask myself some very predictable
questions what happened why did this
happen why did that happen but the most
difficult question I had to get through
was how did I get here and the answer
was even more brutal the answer was
I drove here I had something to do with
it you can't change something until you
own it so if you're 50 plus and you're
sitting out there and pointing fingers
at other people you can do that for a
long time but it's hard to look at the
mirror and say how did I get here and
have the answer be I drove here I had
something to do with it it's
uncomfortable to admit that well I made
some bad decisions I made some
investments I shouldn't have made I had
something to do with it well that man
sold me that house with no money down I
should have told him what he could do
with that house huh when I signed that
adjustable rate mortgage we all know
these things only adjust upwards no
one's ever gonna call you and say guess
what you go pay less for your money your
house next year angle happen so the idea
of I drove here is empowering because
the other side of it is if I drove here
that means I can drive out of here I
have to own it and that bathroom I
finally had to understand what my mama
used to say to me well she would say boy
to Calvary is not coming ain't no backup
I was 28 years old when that part of my
life happened change was coming fast and
you know what changes everywhere all the
time social change technical logical
change and the most potent of all
personal change the most urgent question
today is not so much as what are my
values and who are we the urgent
question on these times of constant
changes how exactly are you going to
navigate these new realities put another
way what are you going to do Story
number five is Howard Schultz whose
advice is your station in life does not
define you I grew up in Brooklyn New
York in public housing the projects as
it was called back then my parents were
both high school dropouts and they could
barely afford
96 dollars a month rent in our
two-bedroom apartment from my brother
and my sister and my parents however for
my earliest of memories my mother
instilled in me her belief in the
American Dream and the promise of
America that a good education and hard
work will open the doors to a better
life and that provides me with an
important lesson to share with you all
today that your station in life does not
define you and the promise of America
that is for all of us
Story number six is Sam and Bud Walton
didn't have any money I bought most of
mine and finally got a you know some of
it paid out out when we left Newport so
it's quite a story but we relied on each
other you are you always to me seemed
like a balance wheel I wanted to gamble
to a greater degree always then maybe
you were ready to do and yeah I would
listen to you we'd argue a little bit
maybe but once we decided we were going
to do go or not go while we were both
together and I think that was that was
something that we can be awfully proud
of
we were Mavericks even then and we were
started doing strange things like
cranking up ice-cream machines on the
sidewalk on Saturday night going on the
other end of the sidewalk honking
anything we get Hong Kong that looked
like it might have a chance to sail
wherever it made an easy life actually
we worked hard that's right but but it
gave us a vehicle to to ride off in
Story number seven the last one before a
very special bonus clip is Conor
McGregor whose advice is to make it
[Music]
when I was a kid he's always visualized
Stadium something and like even when I
was playing football I'd kick the ball
against the wall and I'd pretend that I
scored a goal and I'd run off and I'd be
raising my hand and visualizing a arena
full of fans and so some I don't as a
kid I'm out on my own I like just
running around kicking the ball I always
had these visions of something but I
just didn't know what it was and then I
suppose when I came to this these events
and I started training them and they
came to an event was like okay this is
it this is this is what I'm gonna do and
then now I'm doing but did you ever have
let's call it a normal job Connor at
9:00 to 5:00 yeah because the earliest
thing is the games were trade straight
away my was no different soon as I
finished school I was always getting
passed with what are you doing with your
life you know they still not and they
didn't know what it was they didn't know
if MMA wasn't no no no this didn't know
I could make a career out of as far as
day or consent me mind I'm talking about
as far as they were concerned of just
getting into a cage of fighting some
other guy they didn't know nothing about
it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew well that and then I got end up
getting a trade just to keep them quiet
zhuzi I had a lot a lot of fights meet a
lot like a trade did you get I end up
getting a trade as a plumber how bad was
a diploma
yeah horrendous were you actually in the
trenches I mean it was an industrial
boom so I'd be like building this it'd
be like diploma that would be needed in
a place like this six o'clock in the
morning
than the Molina I just have to walk
through an hour to get them to get there
on motorway and then I stand on the edge
of the motorway and wait for a bloke to
drive boy
so give me a lift and then the motorway
was like a renovation at the time so
take me two or two hours to get to the
place without the country gonna be there
for ten hours walking and I was a first
year so as the worst of the war sermons
on the beginning then two hours to get
back in the traffic again it was just a
horrible horrible time and I was like
you know what I don't want to deal with
this tonight I just left
I lasted 18 18 months still it was tough
you know it just it wasn't I wasn't
alive for me and i'm and then john said
because i was training with john as well
at the time and then john got on twitter
says they have a show on the show we'd
like to fight honey and then that was he
I just packed it in didn't show up
we'd I used to come in and punch the
head on me and like try and drag me out
of bed and I just wouldn't go and I
really hadn't open off for a good few
years when I'm over booked and and that
was it I just packed it in quit and then
focus on training that's I knew I knew I
knew what was gonna happen I knew I was
gonna get here
they didn't there's a lot of stressful
years a lot of tough times
but I proved them wrong I proved myself
right but everything I do in my life is
is related to this I don't do nothing
else it's enough
I mean and that that is why and I meant
it to be true so they're all you've got
to do a show is that not unhealthy I
don't know
do I look unhealthy take a look at this
physique I'm in phenomenal shape in body
and mind to me what's unhealthy is
living an unhealthy life to me what's
unhealthy is getting up and go into the
same day every day I like 9:00 to 5:00
in an officer in it learn that that's
unhealthy that beats your mind I don't I
don't work I wonder why I love what I do
and that's why I'm doing what I love and
I mean that's why that's why it's become
a career for me because I love it
I love what I do
now I've got a very special bonus clip
from John Paul DeJoria around helping
others that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that my question the
day is I want to know what is the most
inspirational rags-to-riches story that
you have ever heard either one that you
watch in this video or another story
that just really inspires you please
leave it down the comments below I
really want to hear from you thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clip
at six years old we didn't have any
money there was my mother my brother and
I we had a deadbeat dad left us before
we were two but she took us at
Christmastime to downtown Los Angeles we
had little cars going around in circles
is pretty cool anyway some decorations
in the window she gave my brother and I
had time until his boys hold half of it
each give to the man ringing the bell in
the bucket we put it in this bucket we
said mom why do we give that man a dime
that's like two soda pops this is 1951
two soda pops free candy bars and mom
said boys that's the Salvation Army now
they take care of people that have no
place to live and no food and we don't
have a lot of money but we could afford
a dime this year boys always remember in
life give a little something to those in
need they'll always be somebody that's
not as well off as you are no matter
where you are how far down you are
trying to have sewing along the way it's
stuck with me raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that that
people passion not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows of
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link the description
for details